speaking on Obamacare and productivity
please welcome dr. Casey Mulligan all
right thank you I'm very glad to be here
I guess just apologize for a couple
little little glitches normally I like
to show allowed to charts and graphs and
put you to sleep the other low glitch I
said don't do my talk during lunch
because it's not very appetizing but
here we are I didn't write the law hey I
just study it so I'm gonna I want to
tell you about a few of the results that
I'm seen in terms of the impact of the
health reform sometimes called Obamacare
sometimes called the Affordable Care Act
specifically the labor market but then
the entire economy you know most of the
economy is about labor and work now we
should remember it the health reform is
very complex piece of legislation a lot
of it deals with and touches the labor
market for sure and that's my area of
expertise but other parts of it relate
to health and medicine and I'm not a
doctor I'm not a biologist I don't want
anybody to bleed even a little bit I'm
going to faint right off the front of
the stage here I don't know about that
okay so what I'm going to tell you today
is my research on the costs and benefits
from an economy or labor market
perspective and it turns out that the
costs outweigh the benefits from a labor
market perspective but i have no
estimate for you today about the health
effects which could be translated into
dollars anything can as an economist
would tell you i can't tell you how much
the health benefits of the ACA are worth
if there are health benefits not my
field
so you can't interpret my remarks today
to say that was bad law we shouldn't
have done it you need that other piece
now as soon as a biologist walks in with
a dollar estimate of the biological or
health benefits of the law you can add
it to the costs that i'll tell you about
and get a bottom line but i'm sorry i
don't have that bottom line today now
the the key economic concept you need to
understand the labor market effects of
the law is what we call tax distortion
so I just want to give you a little
introduction to the idea of tax
distortions distortions a pejorative
term as you'll see it is intentionally
pejorative because tax distortions refer
to the fact that the businesses and
households they change their behavior or
we say distort their behavior in order
to either reduce their taxes or increase
their subsidies and we call it a
distortion because these adjustments to
their behavior are not for real business
reasons or for real personal reasons
they are because of incentives that
taxes are presenting to them an example
i like to use pretty well although in
illinois i always get in trouble with
this example and i'll probably get in
trouble in indiana as well our ethanol
subsidies ethanol actually their credits
technically but that's where gasoline
refiners are subsidized on the basis of
how many gallons of gas they produce
with ethanol of course
right well it subsidizes a certain type
of gas and so one of the store shins you
get is that people change the type of
gas that they use businesses change the
type of gas that they deliver that
affects engine performance and other
things so that's a distortion an example
of a distortion you start using corn for
ethanol instead of corn to feed the cows
that's the distortion arguably I'm not
an agricultural economics but arguably
these subsidies increase food prices
through the reallocation of corn two
different uses and when food prices are
higher that causes restaurants to do
things differently and households to do
things differently so we have another
distortion there and all these things
are basically chasing the subsidy these
aren't done for health reasons or for
business or personal reasons and they're
distortions now that doesn't mean that
we should never have a tax that doesn't
mean we shouldn't have a health reform
it just means do you want to get the
full picture of the costs and benefits
you have to count the tax distortions
and if you want to argue that the text
is worthwhile you've got to say look the
benefits exceed these distortion these
distortion costs and so that's why I'm
going to talk a lot today about taxes
and untaxed distortions now in this
complicated law it helps to narrow it
down a little bit cut it down to just
several hundred pages instead of
thousands to focus on the parts related
to insurance coverage people getting
health insurance and there's four major
categories there and I'm going to really
talk about to just due to time
constraints I'm going to talk about the
exchanges or sometimes they're called
marketplaces where people can buy health
insurance now separate from their
employer and what's important for the
tax perspective is that's where the
assistance is received for most there's
lots of assistance in the law but the
major assistance received there when you
buy your insurance there you can
potentially get a tax credit you can
potentially get government assistance
with your deductible with your
co-payments when you visit the provider
and those sort of things and that's
going to be the number one thing the
second thing is the employer mandate or
the employer penalty that's there so try
to encourage employers to deliver
coverage of course but that has a set of
taxes embedded in there and these taxes
have been discussed in the press the
press have noticed these but I'm going
to explain to you today how the press
has only seen the tip of the iceberg
they're underneath what you've seen
discuss about the employer penalty is a
bunch more really taxation and tax
distortions you put these together the
taxes that are in the marketplace and
the taxes that are part of that penalty
really what the whole pictures really
can be understood pretty simply as we
have put together with various pieces a
full-time employment tax by that I mean
a tax that you pay if you work full-time
at exit you don't pay if you work
part-time the taxi you don't pay if you
don't work at all so that's a full-time
employment tax it different types of
full-time workers are going to
experience it differently depending on
whether employer offers health care if
their employer doesn't offer health care
the way they'll see the full time
employment taxes to the penalty their
employer will have to pay a penalty on
their head essentially as soon as you
leave that employer he won't have to pay
that penalty on your head anymore if you
cut yourself back to to part-time or he
cuts you back to part time you won't
have to pay he won't have to pay that
penalty anymore so it's a tax on your
full-time employment there now if you
work for an employer who does offer
coverage which is most full-time workers
in America there's another tax and that
comes about because you're not entitled
to any of the assistance that comes in
the law the law is full of assistance
for people to get health care but not
for the full time workers whose
employers offer them coverage
that's no politician ever calls that
attacks but that's an implicit text you
might as well have given the imminence
and then send them a tax bill for their
own assistance and that's what's
happening there so the natural result is
if you're going to tax part-time work
and subsidized I mean I'm sorry tax
full-time work or and subsidized
everything else you're going to get less
full-time work and more of everything
else which is not working or part-time
work okay now let me drill down into
those kind of two contributors to the
full-time tax the subsidies in the
marketplaces and the employer penalty
i'll start with the employer penalty as
i said it applies only to full-time
employees and employers that don't offer
the coverage and they apply only during
those months that those employees are on
the payroll so if they're on a temporary
layoff or a furlough or in between jobs
there's no penalty it's just a poundy
when you're working the amount of that
penalty doesn't matter the the dollar
amount doesn't depend on whether you're
rich or poor middle class doesn't matter
you have a head your employer owes
attacks on you this tax is indexed to
health insurance costs so every year
when health insurance costs increase
more than the economy they increase more
than wages the penalty will increase
more than the economy and more and more
than wages the penalty is already
significant is it's going to be done for
the first time in January first so we're
about 90 days away from that or maybe
less and it's usually described as a
two-thousand-dollar penalty it's not
really because the penalty is not
deductible from business taxes any of
you have a business here you know when
you pay wages to your employees you can
deduct that for business tax purposes
you cannot deduct the penalty so really
if you look at in terms of a salary
equivalent the penalty is costing three
thousand dollars a head not two thousand
dollars a head so that's one reason why
this penalty is underestimated the other
reason it's a second reason it's
underestimated it's really
I don't know how to to sugarcoat this
it's anti-competitive in the labor
market it discourages employers for
competing for employees and if your
employee that's a bad deal okay so there
are a lot of employers who are not going
to pay the penalty and so you won't see
revenue from it and you won't see the
press put emphasis because this is a tax
it's not bringing as much revenue as it
could I guess but employers our
employees are still going to suffer
because an employer doesn't pay a
penalty you might think oh he has an
advantage in the market because he's
penalty free but if he starts to use
that advantage by actually hiring people
he becomes a large employer and his
subject to the penalty so this penalty
is almost as if it was well designed to
discourage employers from competing for
employees and that's what it that's it
what it does the third reason that it's
underestimated its importance and its
tax distortion effects is it
disproportionately hits low-skilled
workers and the way I like to think
about is think for any worker think
about how many hours they have to work
every week all year round to produce
three thousand dollars worth of value so
that their employer could rationalize
that penalty on their head okay for a
minimum wage worker they have to work
eight hours every week all year round
that'd be like if I talk from now until
dark okay with no bathroom breaks that's
what a minimum-wage employee would have
to endure for free in order to produce
the value to pay that penalty one day a
week of work for the government through
this one provision of course employees
pay other taxes as well but that's at
one one day a week now there are other
employees obviously who can produce
three thousand dollars worth of value
per year with a in less time and it will
obviously be less important for them but
for those low-wage workers it's huge
okay let's move to the marketplaces and
let me tell you how the marketplaces
have been underappreciated in terms of
their
tax distortions they create imagine a
scheme what's first of all imagine it's
not hard for you imagine imagine painful
a price for your health care together
with your employer or yourself how does
full price work well you pay the full
price they don't look at your tax return
the full price is the full price and so
we would never call paying full price
for your health care and income tax of
any kind you go ahead and earn more
going to pay the same price go ahead an
less pay the same price full prices full
price now imagine we had a discount on
the full price thirty percent off for
everybody regardless of their income
again that's not an income tax that's a
discount okay but what if we tied the
discount to your employment situation
not to your income but we tied it to
your employment situation well that's
how the marketplaces work remember what
I said earlier if you have a full-time
job I had an employer that offers
coverage which is where most employees
in this economy work you don't get the
discount no discount for you you want to
get that discount you better become a
part-time worker or spend time off the
job that's how you get the discount so
really it's an employment tax our
full-time employment tax as i said
earlier because the discount only goes
to people who don't work full time or
don't work at all so we have an
employment tax a full-time employment
text there now I oversimplified a little
it it's not just one discount for
everybody the discount also depends on
your income so there's an income tax
there the more you earn the less of a
discount you again and if you aren't
enough the discount would be zero so
that's an income tax this is where one
of the big mistakes came in Washington
and analyzing these rules they just
focus on the income tax they said AHA
there's an income tax but there's only
eight million people on the exchanges
okay eight million people have a new
income tax that'll have some little
effect on blah blah blah that doesn't
make the employment tax go away that I
just mentioned that it's not just that
they're penalizing you for earning
income but there regardless of what your
income is they're penalizing you for
working full time work in particular
so there's two taxes big taxes put into
those marketplaces the I told you this
wasn't going to be advertising built
into those exchanges and employment tax
at the same time that there's an income
tax and you have to have to count them
both and you won't can't read about this
employment tax anywhere except my three
dollar book which is a shame it's really
been a nope see for America that all the
economic analysis of this law does not
none of it mentions the employment tax
and it's the single biggest tax in the
law and obviously employment taxes
affect employment that's attacks
something you get less of it you look at
the size of that employment tax again I
like to express it in terms of how many
hours per week would somebody have to
earn to create the value to pay for the
health care that the government's not
paying for them because they work and
here's where it can get pretty ugly
there are a number of people who may
have to work 10 20 30 hours a week to
create the kind of value that they would
get for free if they didn't work under
the new system I if I had my charts and
graphs I could take you through an
example of somebody who is not a minimum
wage worker $26 on our worker and
they're comparing full-time vs part-time
in the old days part-time meant your and
less and your family has less to spend
nowadays that was a family of four $26
an hour worker they can actually their
family can spend more and have more if
the worker works part-time and the
reason is part time turns on at that
level fifteen thousand dollars a year
with the subsidies more than a thousand
a month where the subsidies is turned on
by giving up those 11 hours in your
schedule and I'm not talking about the
employer penalty here this is this is
just from the marketplaces and we've put
I'm not saying everyone in the economy
is that in situation but we have a few
million people who are in that
situation we'll see how long it takes
them to figure it out that by cutting
their hours back from 40 to 29 hours
their family can actually have more
their bank okay it can grow more or
shrink less than working full time and
that is a what can I say it's a perverse
economically perverse situation that is
not something to be bragging about or to
be proud about that that's a big problem
now one reaction I got it probably won't
get it in it in this type of crop but
one reaction I get is wait a second so
what if the government takes ninety
percent of your income you still have
the incentive to maximize that ten
percent
and everybody's desperate for a job and
so tech taxing people's employment tax
and their income won't affect what
they'll do and that's you guys left you
know that's that wrong it's against
common sense we have decades of research
showing that when you have a tax you get
less of what you taxi for tax labor you
get less labor on average doesn't mean
everybody every worker response to every
labor tax no that's not true that's a
strong man but the research shows that
on average the attacks labor you get
less labor and what the Affordable Care
Act is doing is its taxing employment
it's taxing income we're going to get
less employment less income the other
thing about this this story about people
maximizing their little 10% piece is
it's partly as I just explained in some
cases it's a straw man for some people
the way to maximize your income is to
work less because of the economically
economic perversions in this law so
that's um that's one things going to
affect value created in our economy you
have fewer people working we're going to
have less value created those people are
working and we're working before the law
to create value for their employer for
themselves so that's one way we're going
to lose productivity the other way we're
going to lose productivity to each each
hour of work that we have people some
people will still continue to work each
hour will be less productive as well and
let me explain a little bit how that
works you go back to the the ethanol
example where people are adjusting their
behavior whether it's what they buy or
how they use the fuel or how they grow
the corn they're adjusting their
behavior in order to increase subsidies
reduce taxes well that's going on with
the Affordable Care Act and we'll go on
even more as it rolls out businesses
will change the way they do business
they may have more part-time employees
than full-time employees not because
that creates value but because it avoids
penalties or enhances subsidies the
Chicago Cubs had kind of an infamous
example of
of that this summer where they changed
over to more part-time employees and
they had a day where they the ground
crew could not handle the weather and
that reduce the value of the game for
the fans in general and so you lost
productivity there because because of
those kinds of incentives the other on
there are many areas in which this will
happen you'll see firms bend over
backwards to stay below 50 employees not
because 49 employees is something your
customers love it's not because it
somehow makes the machines run quicker
49 employees is a way to escape some of
the taxes and penalties and so we're
going to lose productivity that way now
another thing I've seen in the in the
analysis of the law is this kind of you
that okay if your if your employer pays
the penalty you're probably harmed but
then again not many players and play
that kind of pay the penalty that so the
story goes that this is wrong Adam Smith
said that was wrong and let me just
quote him briefly Adam Smith said in the
wealth of nations he said look if
there's any employment that's evidently
more advantageous or less advantageous
than the rest so many people would crowd
into it in the one case or deserted in
the other that its advantages would CERN
soon return to the level of other
employments so what does that mean here
well penalties disadvantageous okay a
subsidy is advantageous so what's going
to happen is some workers will directly
experience the penalty but all their
workers the economy will experience
because workers will move out of their
customers will move out of that industry
or away from that firm is that penalty
is passed on in cost and will all
experience it and none of the certainly
none of the advocates analysis of this
law recognized that you had amicus brief
in the end this in this case about
whether certain states should be
getting the subsidies and having the
penalties the economist put in amicus
brief didn't use any Adam Smith
economics they take this view that and
then they build these so-called
sophisticated models in which nothing
happens to you except what happens
directly to you and your employer if it
happens to another employer doesn't
affect you if it happens to another
employee doesn't affect you and that's
just wrong and Adam Smith showed it
wrong and it dramatically changes the
answers so that's one reason we're kind
of getting I've listed two reasons why
you've kind of been hearing the wrong
answer on this number one they don't
realize all the taxes that are in there
number two they're not thinking like an
Adam Smith type of economists and trying
to understanding the productivity
patterns that it will result the third
mistake that's been made is to point to
Massachusetts Massachusetts had another
number of health reforms would I find
fascinating but they point to Romneycare
when Governor Romney i think was 2006
passed a health care law that on paper
looks like at least a headline level
looks like obamacare they had exchanges
they had subsidies on those exchanges
they had employer penalties a lot of the
words that I talked about today you
could find those words in Romneycare and
they said look after they rolled out
Romneycare you didn't see any obvious
economic problems that were specific to
Massachusetts we happen to go through a
great recession right after that but
there was nationwide not just
Massachusetts and I agree with that I've
looked at the data and you don't see
Massachusetts being all that unusual
economically compared to its neighboring
states and so then for example the
Department of Health and Human Services
says stop whining about the penalties
stop whining about these things
Massachusetts proves that we can do this
without any disruption or here's the
problem that
you can go out and measure the taxes in
Romneycare just like I've gone on and
measured the taxes in Obamacare and you
can you can talk about how many hours
per week does somebody have to work to
pay the Romney care penalty okay I said
the minimum wage worker here has to pay
has to work eight hours they have to
work about 35 minutes to pay the Romney
cure penalty okay eight hours a week for
the government versus 35 minutes weeks
not the same thing they're not going to
have the same effect same with the
exchanges and I Obamacare exchanges I
mentioned some people may have to work
10 20 hours a week to pay for that
assistance they're not getting under
Romneycare / 10 / 20 so Obamacare is
really increasing the tax on the labor
market by something like 12 13 14 times
more than Romneycare did in
Massachusetts so the effects would be
something like 12 13 14 times more maybe
18 maybe eight I don't know but they're
order magnitude different and so we
shouldn't take any comfort from the
Massachusetts experience there so just
to conclude or to summarize this health
reform it's got three major taxes in it
two of them are taxes on full-time
employment one of them is a tax on
income they may be implicit they may be
hidden Metropolitan's may not call them
taxes but that's exactly what they are
the economic significance of these taxes
varies widely across workers especially
the low-skilled workers that I discuss
another situation size of the firm and
so on and that creates all kind of
productivity problems these new taxes
because this is not the first time we've
ever seen attacks we've been able to
look at taxes historically Texas matter
these new taxes are going to have a
visible at the aggregate level visible
and permanent effect on the economy i
estimate that employment will be three
percent less forever because of the
reform and national
will be or GDP if you like to think of
it that way will be two percent less
maybe another way to look at it is that
if you look at the productivity costs
alone forgetting about the fact that
there'll be number of people not working
anymore does the productivity of the
workers who remain those costs alone are
six thousand dollars per person who gets
health insurance because of the law I
estimate by the way a lot of people will
eventually get health insurance because
the law and that that's another story
why I actually kind of bullish on that
but when you express these product TV
costs on a per insured basis is six
thousand dollars per year per insured
and this time not beginning to count the
payments you need to make the nurses and
doctors and health care providers to
take care of them I'm saying on top of
that everyone all of us are less
productive to the tune of six thousand
dollars per case so my promise to you is
if you like your weak economy you can
keep it
so we've gotten glad to take any
questions comments
right in the middle please wait for the
microphone please thank you very much my
question is and during your talk you
mentioned that you see the Obamacare
impact partially being I think
depressing output and therefore GDP and
that goes back to your last statement
the economy will be weakened weaker is
that correct two percent two percent
lower every every year take some rollout
time but by 2017 will see two percent
less than we would have without the law
and in 20 27 will see two percent less
than we would have without the law and
so on forever so it's a permanent
deduction and were therefore we will be
as a nation worse off with this than
without it well if you save enough lives
lives are very valuable and health care
is being healthy is something people
value a lot if you were able to save
enough lives you could rationalize that
cost I like I said beginning I don't I
don't have that exemption can we saved
more lives Thank You Graham if you lose
lives it's another story I it may kill
people i don't i just hope their medical
analysis better than their economic
analysis that's all I'll say about that
following up on your prediction you said
we'd have three percent less employment
on infinitum economists usually use
multipliers when they talk about the
impact of things in the economy won't we
have more than three percent because as
three percent less of us are employed
and gaining income then we don't go to
the supermarket we don't go and buy
other things which is then going to
result in less employment throughout the
economy and it's going to be a
multiplier and it's not just going to be
three percent bad it's going to be 3.1
3.2 3.3 now you can't multiply it
already I've already taken care of all
that
so three percent of three percent you
want to make people more nauseous come
on professor dr. ben Carson md publicly
rebuked Obama if we could get him
elected is there any chance we can
reverse all this with a new president
I'm not a political expert but I know
how matches work give me the stack of
papers light them on fire it's pretty
simple you go back to where we were
which wasn't perfect but it would be
three percent more than then when we're
getting nowhere close to perfect before
thank you dr. Mulligan what if any
distorting effects might there be from
the current issue right now which is
Medicaid expansion under the law I
didn't get to discuss discuss that
there's a couple of effects there there
are under the old Medicaid system there
were people who are holding back their
work in order to remain eligible for
Medicaid and the expansion will allow
them to hold back a little less while
under a little more so that would be an
increase in in work behavior among a
certain type of people now there's be
another class of people who are actually
induced to work less because they
weren't eligible for any kind of
Medicaid anyway and those are roughly
offsetting and they're also focused
among low-wage people so for GDP type of
conclusions that doesn't matter a whole
lot now if you're interested in a
specific impoverished population I think
you'd want to look a lot closer than I'd
be able to show you today on that on
them
my question has to do with information
economics and Joe public's ability to
read the situation correctly as for his
economic fallout from the health care
reform on the physician and anecdotally
I see plenty of examples where the half
of the equation that you say you can't
address will be a negative 14 patients
for instance a retired CEO who recently
told me at the end of the visit that his
insurance had changed and he showed me
the insurance and we said this is an
Obamacare product and he was shocked he
didn't know what he had bought his
previous plan he liked but it got
canceled so he couldn't keep it and so
I'm just wondering if the politics of
the whole thing and the left's ability
to win the argument convincing people
that more government to ride in on a
white horse and rescue the situation
every time when they in effect are the
root cause of the problems is Joe public
going to be able to see through if I'm
correct and the medical part of it is a
negative for him and other than
subsidies that he might get to encourage
him his economic behavior to like it
imbalance is he going to be able to see
through the politics of the empty
promises of more government will fix it
as it continues to not work politics is
kind of an ameture area for me but uh if
you like I'll give an ammeter answer I
think a lot of Americans they may not
have taken economics courses or whatever
they understand intuitively the basic
problems with collective arrangements
socialism communism or whatever I was
pleasantly surprised how they saw the
stimulus they didn't most of America I
think didn't see the stimulus is all
that stimulating they knew that the
politicians were not given them a
straight story they might not have
for sure they probably can articulate
why not so I think they'll have the same
kind of intuition here now whether their
opinion matters so I hope it does and it
did matter in the sense that we didn't
get a second stimulus and so maybe we
won't try this thing again maybe we
won't grow it but again that's that's an
amateur answer I don't I don't
specialize in political analysis please
right in front there you go thank you
that was great since you've studied this
so much and they're going to be a lot of
reform proposals what kind of things
should we look for in a reform proposal
do you have ideas about that I
definitely I don't have ideas light it
on fire okay that's one
but I do know what to look for and maybe
you're not gonna like me what I say this
a lot of times I see Democrats or
Republicans is like Coke and Pepsi
chemically identical but very different
advertising and I saw coming out of it I
love the Manhattan Institute they they
do so many good things but I saw a
proposal come out of the Manhattan
Institute that had all the problems i
just listed today that the taxi me
employment taxing income very heavily
I'm going to just repackaging you know
the same the same problems now that's
not there are plans out so that's what I
look for I had asked the question does
this proposal tax employment or tax
incomes in addition to all the other
taxes unemployment incomes we already
have separate from the health law that's
the kind of question I asked and there
are plans out there that don't and their
plans are out there that do and one
thing I wonder my can I an ax murder
political analysis maybe the political
forces for redistribution art is too
strong and even the Republicans won't be
able to resist them and so you're going
to have to politically whatever Party
opaque is going to deliver to you a lot
of redistribution which means people who
earn and work don't get as much health
or if any does the three percent medical
device tax add into any of your equation
and other more taxes in there that are
sort of like that there are lots I not
even sure I could put a count on it but
it's in the dozens of taxes but they as
you go down the list they get smaller
and smaller the medical device tax is
it's important for some specific
industries but an aggregate level it's
quite small maybe it does more damage
per dollar revenue it does I haven't
looked at that but it's just small on
that on the aggregate side that the
biggies as I said are these marketplace
subsidies are huge player penalties
quite big and then you kind of go down
the list from there
I can attest to your presumption of a
slowdown in production last month I have
quit for the year in earnings I'm just
working on my house now and socializing
things like that I have been investing
in robotics companies and technology
wondering you're talking about the
reduction in GDP and of course income am
i foolish to be investing in robotics
thinking that it's going to replace
workers fill in that gap from reduced
hourly productivity because we're going
to have less money overall or will
automation fill in that gap and still
keep welcome production up I love that
question I would think it in two parts
quantities and prices okay and on the
quantity cider which is how many robots
we're going to have or what types of
technologies you're going to have on how
many of them there I think you want to
look at Europe is kind of a model
they've done this already long ago and
you can see there are a lot less
labor-intensive and a lot of things they
do you go to a fast food place in Europe
and then you serve yourself okay and
we'll have that same sort of thing so
definitely the quantity of Labor
substitutes will be higher that I'm
confident about yeah you're asking me
about investing notes is more about the
price and there I can't be sure I don't
know how much that's already built into
the market or what have you I would
assume investors out there in the market
kind of thought of what i just said
along before I thought of it and i've
kind of built in to their projections
that hey we're going to be more European
in the way we run our economy which
means more labour substitutes and less
labor exactly
final question
do you think Obamacare is the next step
toward complete government control of
medical care yeah i'm not sure what
scale to measure things inc Singson the
public sector has been heavily involved
in medicare for a long time and now it's
more heavily involved i guess one thing
to keep in mind off a lot of medicare's
for the elderly medical care is for the
elderly and Obamacare is primarily a non
elderly type of program so in that sense
for the medical point of view it kind of
limits its impact now medic there are
some Medicare provisions I didn't get to
talk about an Obamacare that that do fit
in there so if I were watching for a
government takeover of medical care i
would pay attention to the elderly
elderly experience because they're using
an awful lot of the health care for
obvious reasons
thank you dr. Mulligan that's a
fascinating subject and one that affects
every single person in this room we will
begin our two o'clock panel in the other
area where we were this morning so we're
looking forward to the panel on the
finances of American cities that's
another aspect of the economy one small
housekeeping note we have a couple of
teachers here from the toledo ohio area